皆さんこんにちは石井美帆です
ええまあ宇宙からですね地球に行こう話題が降りてきますけれどもあの皆さんこの会場
は今日博物館の中にありますけどもすでに博物館をまだパワられた方はいますか
いないですねあの私はですね人類学者として皆さんに今日ちょっと違う博物館の回り方
をお勧めしたいと思います
皆さんは普段ですね博物館を回る時は10時にこう集中していると思うんですねです
けれども私がおすすめしたいのはその拳児の背後にある仕掛けとかですね仕組みに着岸
するという風な見方ですねでとは言っても実際にその10時の背後に何かカラクリが
あるというのではなくってそのどのように開示されているとか
どのようにご照明が落ちているとかどんな風な純度で進むように誘導されているかとか
ですね
そういうことをひっくるめて仕掛けとかまあ仕組みというふうに言えると思う
いますでそうした仕掛けとか仕組みというのは普段はその展示物の背後に隠れてしまっ
て私たちにとってはあまり気づかないものですけれども
でも実際にはですねそうした仕掛けとか仕組みがあることによって私たちがその展示物
とどういう風に向き合うかあるいはこの館の中をどういうふうに動きのあるか
いうことが方向づけられているわけですね
で実はそうした仕掛けや仕組みというのは私たちの日常生活の中にも多くあるわけです
ね
でその多くはその公共空間の中に見てとることができると思いますで例えば皆さんあの
よく使われる駅ですけれども
あの日本ではですね例えば大阪なんかの都市ではエスカレーターの3
湯川2号人形って左側を急いでる人が登ったり置いたりするっていう風なシステムに
なってると思うんですね
ところがその大阪以外のところに行くとその並ぶ方向が逆だったりするわけですね私の
ようにあの大阪で生まれ育って初めて喉頭鏡なんかに行くと最初はその列に並ぶ方向町
が
手をまごまごしたりするんですけどもだんだんとこうみんなこっちに並んでるなぁと
いう感じで
その自分の行動を修正するようになるんですね
でこれはいわばその役っていう公共空間において自然発生的に
まあカッコ付きですけれども合理的な仕組みが生まれていったらいいかと思います
つまり
動く会談
階段であるところのエスカレーターと急いでる人とそれほど急いでない人っていう風な
人と物の組み合わせがですねそういうふうな仕組みを勝手にこう作り出しているわけ
ですね
誰がそうしろと言ったわけでもないけれど
ですけれども一旦そういうふうな仕組みができてしまうとそれはその場所に置いてある
種のルールですとかマナーみたいな形で私たちの行動を規制していくようになるんで
さらには私たちがそれにすっかり慣れてしまうとまた加工当たり前のこととしてもなく
なっていくわけですね透明化するといってもいい
んですけれども
ですけれども入ったんですねもし私が例えば
まあ体がちょっと不自由になったりしてその今ある人と物のスムースな仕組みに乗れ
なくなってしまったときに今まで当たり前だと思っていたそうした仕組みや仕掛けが実
はそんなに
当たり前のもじゃなかったいう形で
御姿を現してくることがあるわけですね
であるいはその人とモノが作り出しているその仕組みなんですけれどもその人とモノの
関係が何かずれちゃった
うまくいかなくなった時にもそういう仕組みがあらわになるということがあるかと思い
ます
で人類学がどういう学問かというのはまあ諸説ありますけれども私が思うのは一つに
あるんですね
私たちの日常生活の中でそうした
見えなくなっちゃってるような仕組みや仕掛けというものにもう一度
光を当ててその引っ張り出すことによってどういうふうにそれが私たちの行動とか考え
方を魔法
上野たり導いたりしているのかということを考え
ことですねでそれを通してある種の世界の成り立ちみたいなものを考え直すという学問
だと言えます
言い換えると透明化してしまったような仕組みや論理みたいなものをもう一度
不透明化する学問だと言えます
じゃあどういう時にそういう仕組みや仕掛けが不当不自然なものとしてあらわになるか
というと
さっきも言いましたようにその人とモノの関係がうまくいかなくなった時あるいは既に
ある仕組みにまた別の仕組みみたいなものが入ってきた時にその間にこうコンフリクト
が起こった
すると思いますけれどもそうしたときに
おかしいなこれは当たり前のもじゃなかったっていうふうに新しく
その物事を捉え直すことができると思うんですね
今日はですね私が調査をしているあの南インドの
カルナータカバンガローってこのあたりですけれどもこの事例を使ってですね皆さんに
そうした例をちょっとご紹介したいと思います
と思っ
皆さんこの写真を見てどういう風に感じられますかね
あのごく普通の外国のショッパ市街地のように見えるかと思います
ですがところがちょっと離れて見てみるとさっき示した写真というのはですね実はこの
山の上にそびえている巨大なあの工業地帯の一部なんですね
その周りにはこういうふうに深い森林が生い茂ってましてその下の方に
まあの農地があるわけです
でこれはマンガロール経済特区って呼ばれていますまあ巨大な経済特区でさっきのよう
なその農村地帯の真ん中に号竜助として
できてるんですけどもまぁ最新のテクノロジーを駆使してですね
石油化学関連の工業地帯ができていますであの多くは多国籍企業でインド国内のみなら
ず
世界中から一流のエンジニアたちが集まっているわけですね
でつまりこういうむき出しの第1と全くノロジーと機械からなる世界ですねそれが経済
特区と言えると思います
ところがそれを取り巻いているのは a 農村世界でさっきの経済特区とは全く違う
仕組みとか論理で動いている世界ですね
でその中でもあの面白いのですね
ここでぶーたっていうぷシンガーという風に書いてますけど
土地の神様の最新ですねそれをお祀りしています
でそのぶーたっていうのが何かというとあのその土地の神様とも言われてますし
この辺りにいる虎ですとか
いの cc とか蛇みたいに野生動物の奴隷ですね
スピリットとも言われてますしあるいはその水田を取り巻いている野生の自然の領域の
力そのものだ
っていう風にも言われています
で年に一度ですねこの村の有力者の人たちがおっきなを待つ量を開きまして
この真ん中にいるのがよりマシですね
スピットミディアムっていうふうに言いますけれどもそのよりマシにぶーたが好評いし
てくる
乗り移るわけですねでそれを通してお告げをつけたりするんですけれどもそうした
よりマシに憑依した do たと村の漁師たちが直接にをやり取りをするわけですね
ってそのまま次の中でこれは村の領主の一番以来人ですけれども彼がそのブータに
農作物を
供物してそれを受け取ったブータはですねその見返りに来年もこの村を祝福してですね
豊作を与えるというふうに約束する今したことがもうずっとですね何十年も何百人も
行われてきたというふうに言われています
でところはですねさっきもみました経済特区っていうのは基本的にはあのそうした土地
とか土地の神様に依存したような世界ではなくって
ま農地とかですね山林を切り開いて更地にしてその上にこういう近代的な工場を建てて
いる
ってそこで働いている人たちもですねそういう風ね no 3
とは違っての土地とか土地の神様に依存した生活をしているわけではなくって基本的に
は
ちんロード中じしているわけですね
でこういうふうに見てきますと
いわばその伝統的なその農村世界のそれを作り出しているような論理や仕組みが近代的
なですね
ノンリア仕組みですね近代合理的なそれーと変わっていって一元化されていっている
そういう風に見えるかもしれません
でところはですね現実はそんな風に単純には進まなかったわけですね
この経済特区というのは実際は第1段階から第2段階を経て第3段階まで
ものすごい規模で拡大することがあの計画されてたんですね
農村をすべては壊していくような勢いってところが2011年にですね第2段階
の途中でこの開発というのが止まってしまうんです
それはなぜか
一つにはですね地域の農民を中心とする人たちが大規模な反開発運動を行ったという
ことがあります
で彼らにとっては農民ですので土地を開発によって奪われて他の地域に
たちのパされることはまさに死活問題なわけですねでそれだけじゃなくてこの土地と
いうのは彼らにとってそのさっき言いましたブータと呼ばれる神様と深く結びついて
いるわけなので
自分たちだけそのブータを置いて会がそのブータをお祀りしている
やしろおいて別の地域にいくっていうことは許されないわけですね
でかやるわけじゃなくってその社会運
評価ですねアクティビストたちがその彼らをサポートする中でそうした
ブータを置いて私はいけませんっていう彼らの論理をですねこれは農民たちの伝統文化
なんだという形で別の形に読み替えることでメディアに紹介していくわけです
でそうした形でその版開発運動っていうのが本当に代休風に盛り上がっていったことを
とうとうですねカルナータカ州も無視できなくなってですね州首相が2011年にこれ
以上を開発することは禁ずるという風な命令を下すということになったわけです
でそれだけではなくてまぁさっき外体幹を観ていただいた経済特区のですね工業
プラントの中でも実は変化が起こっていました
でさっき申し上げましたとおり経済特区というのは基本的にはあの近代テクノロジーと
ま経済合理性とですね雪花機会と人の協働関係によって動いているような世界ですね
まぁでその仕組みがうまく回っている限りにおいてはそういう仕組みにここに働いて
いる人たちが疑問も
打つことはないわけですね
ところがこの工業プラントの中では非常に頻繁に事故とかですね
機械の不具合とかそうした問題が起こっていたわけですで特に2011年にはですね
その海外から来たエンジニア数名を含む
あの数人が講師称してしまうような大規模なあの人身事故というのが起こってし
なりました
でこういうふうに真人とそれを使うですねその人々が使っているものとの関係性に後期
シミが生じるような事態が起きたときにこの経済特区の幹部たちは今の
そのことの問題に技術的な対処するだけでは無理だと
何かこの経済特区それ自体を犯している仕組みに問題があるんじゃないかというふうな
見方が出てくるわけですね
でそれで彼らがどうしたかというとこの写真に写っていますけれどもその外からですね
彼らはその占星術子達ですけれどもは占いをする人たちですねで彼らを呼んできて
この相次ぐ事故の背後にある別の仕組み
別の論理みたいなものは何かというのを明らかに
しようとしたわけですでこの占星術とまさにここはこの給付プラントの中でこれは
オフィスの中でこうやって綺麗をやってるんですけども
フルを通して何がいわれたかと言いますとその相次ぐ事故というのはこの経済特区を
取り巻いている
森林地帯ですねそこのその野生の力つまりアブーた後からですけれどもそれが
引き起こしているんだということがいわれたわけですね
でその野生の力とこの経済特区との関係をうまくを調整するためにはこの経済と口の中
に
ぶー耕しをつくってお祀りしなさいという風なお告げが
占星術を通して付けられるわけです
でそれを聞いた企業幹部の人たちはですね実際にこの中でしすごく立派なですね
ぶー店や城を建ててそこでお祭りを始めるということをするわけですね
で先ほどみましたようにその農民たちにとってはそもそもその
ブータの祭祀を通して野生の領域とやり取りをしてその力をですね
蓄えて濃厚に役立てるいうふうな非常に高
農民的な世界というものがいわばこう自然なものとして受け取られて
たわけですところがそこにこう開発というものが入ってくることによっていままで
言ってみれば自然な論理として受け取られていたそのブータの妻子というのが彼らの
伝統文化なんだ
いう形で別の形でトライなおされるということが起こるんですね
で一方で者経済特区の方はですねさっきも言いましたように基本的にはテクノロジーと
経済合理性によって動いているあるいは人と機械の親密な関係性の上で成り立ってるん
ですけれどもそこにマージかという小物が起こってですねその仕組み自体が疑問視され
た時に今度
信頼妻子という全く別の仕組みとか論理というものが導入されてくる
でそのことを通して今まで非常に強固なものだと思えていたようなそういう近代
テクノロジーですとかまぁ経済合理性という風な仕組みとか仕掛けそのものが実はそれ
ほど万能のもじゃなかったあるいはその野生の力の影響を受けるような情弱なものだっ
たんじゃないかっていう風な意識が
え人々と間に保たれるようになってくるという風に言えます
これはですね言ってみればその農村社会の仕組みとか論理と経済特区の仕組みと論理と
いう愛子となる仕組みは論理がこの漫画レールのある地域でですね
どやって非常に親密に絡み合うことを通して
それぞれがそれぞれの世界で自然なものとしてまー透明化していたような仕組みがそう
ではないものとして別の形でですね
捉え直されたそういう事例かなというふうに言えるかと思います
で最初に申し上げましたようにあの
私たちの身の回りというのは実に様々なあの明文化されてないですね
人と物の組み合わせからなるようなその仕組みとか仕掛けによってできているわけで
私たちは知らないうちにそれに従ったりとかあるいはそれを再生産したりしているわけ
です
ん
ただそういう仕組みとか仕掛けが自分にとって幸
それほど自然なものじゃないものとして表れてくるときというのはヒトとモノの関係性
がうまくいかなくなった時ですね
で例えばですね私たちの身近で言えば災害などがそうしたきっかけとしてあるかと思い
ますけれどもそうしたまあ究極的な事態ではなくってもちょっと視点を変えて見てです
ねさっきのエスカレーターの例ではないですけど
異邦人になったつもりでですね5世界を見てみるとまさにですね
今まで自分が自然なものとして思ってみた
あの論理とか仕組みみたいなものがですね当たり前じゃないものとして見えてくるかな
と思います
でそういうふうにこう自分の視点もこうずらして違うものとして世界を見てみることの
利点はあの
世界を多様化するという風なだけじゃなくって
自分自身の行動の選択肢を増やしたりとかですね
あるいはちょっとわざとですねずらしてみたい
そういうふうな形である種自分自身をを柔軟にすることにもつながると思いますで
さっき経済特区がですねこんな風にどんどん校
ノン世界に進出してくるかに見えたようにあの知らないうちにですねある仕組みとか
仕掛けみたいなものが明示化されることなく私たちの行動を一元化していっているよう
なケーキというのはあると思うんですね今の日本でもひょっとしたらそういうことが
のまにかをとっているかもしれない私たちはその目に見えない仕組みにいつのまにか
したがっているかもしれないわけです
でですけれども心霊妻子がそうだったように一見マイナーに見える
正論理とか4組っていうものですねちょっと持ってくることで
それがその他生かされてそうじゃない世界の可能性
そうじゃない世界のあり方みたいなものが部分的にでもですね
見えてくる可能性はあるかと思います
同人霊学のやっぱり仕事というのはそういう形でまぁ透明化している
見えない仕組みみたいなものを1回不透明にして見ることによって世界の
別のあり方の可能性を増し示すということじゃないかなと思いますありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]